des cris des flashes et sourire le jury
du 46e festival de cannes présidé par
louis malle arrive au pied des marches
rituel respecter religieusement
c'est encore et toujours la fièvre du
tapis rouge qui donne le signal de
départ en route pour cannes 93
cette soirée c'est avant tout celle de
daniel auteuil
catherine deneuve andré téchiné marthe
villalonga ma saison préférée fill mot
d'ouverture
cette soirée c'est aussi celle de ce
public cinq mille personnes environ qui
de loin et said apercevoir les stars
hippolyte girardot maître de cérémonie
lio très remarqué
claudia schiffer très remarqué également
jacques toubon ministre de la culture
cris flash sourire en route pour 15 93